les dufresne vigneron de père en fils
depuis le 14e siècle ce n'est ni dans le
bordelais ni en bourgogne mais à
argenteuil au pied des hlm jacques
dufresne continue de cultiver 2000
mètres carré de vigne la fin d'une
tradition car son fils ne reprendra pas
le vignoble
je suis mort de soixante dix ans déjà
pas mal bon on est décent descend d'une
famille depuis treize 142 on monte notre
arbre généalogique à argenteuil tous
vivre ont depuis tous vignon jusqu'à mon
père était encore presque exclusivement
vignerons après ça on sait qu on
reconvertit surtout dans la culture
fruitière et puis je m'abstiens juste un
peu un petit carré de vigne pour
maintenir la tradition d'accueil encore
une vigne argenteuil chesnais de fresnes
le vin c'est une affaire de famille
jacques le petit dernier le mali le
sécateur depuis son plus jeune âge par
passion par tradition et chaque automne
c'est le même cérémonial la vendange
avec les amis les histoires de vignes et
de vignerons il les connaît par coeur et
toujours il parle avec nostalgie de la
grande époque c'était vers 1800
argenteuil était alors la première
commune viticole de france mille
hectares de vignes 5000 barriques de vin
qui alimentait les gosiers parisien
avant que ne survienne le déclin les
cloches malepère d'arrivée ils ont
commencé à avoir des vins de la loire
qui était souvent meilleurs que les
nôtres
puis les vins de la vallée du rhône puis
les vins du midi sont arrivés et à ce
moment là la vigne ici par ici est tombé
en désuétude
bah on peut dire que jusqu'en 1960 la
trentaine de l'exploitant agricole qui
avait encore sur argenteuil faisait
lanvin il pape est arrivé la grande
urbanisation alors là les vignes sont
disparus les gens n'ont portland non
pour planter seul jacques de fresnes a
su défier le béton et quand le raisin
prend la direction du pressoir un parfum
d'exotisme plane sur argenteuil
les promeneurs
et suprême fabre les caractéristiques de
votre vin sont classés d'un vin blanc
sec qui rappelle à bord muscadet où un
vent de la mer certains vendent la
moselle où des voix russe calais apports
des bombes de gros plan un peu voyez
parole de vignerons la cuvée 92
s'annonce abondante plus de 500
bouteilles
un vin n'en déplaise aux curieux
exclusivement destinée à sa consommation
personnelle